citizens of the reject Nation welcome to the
first Bostonian team up on the reject Nation
I'm here with the ever lovely ever effervescent
ever World girly Roxy's try how are you doing
do you think that's true we're the first two-time
Boston people on the show two-time returning
Champions some people are gonna love this
who else would it be uh maybe Jason Tatum
he's in here all the time uh Mark Wahlberg
Ben Affleck pops by should we go back and
forth with them Mark Wahlberg I just said
that I came in with Mark Wahlberg I was distracted
to that picture Matt Damon and so it threw
me because that's why I went Ben Affleck sometimes
I see Matt when you say Mark um some other
woman I don't know why when I think of Boston
I only come up with man John Krasinski B.J
Novak yeah there's a lot of dudes yeah where
are the women speaking of women this movie
might have some but we don't know that because
we haven't seen it this is our first watch
of the thing a movie I got a lot of crap about
having not seen yeah me too for a really long
time people have said that this is the best
body horror movie and I've never seen it and
I'm excited to be able to shut people down
now we're gonna watch the thing please do
like subscribe hit that notification Bell
leave a comment below of which is your favorite
Bostonian US hunt Roxy down on world girls
they got a lot of cool stuff I like that new
tracksuit please do check this out as well
over on patreon if you want to watch it front
to back sink to sync start to finish with
us just watching the whole time that's how
you get it here on YouTube you can see you
know pieces of our experience if you want
the entire Journey including our resting watching
faces like this that's where you go over the
patreon to hunt us down there and let's watch
the thing
[Music] good
I actually don't know much John Carpenter
work which is crazy because I know that I
do this for a living and he's like the God
of this but it was like just before our time
like are you saying we're young yeah
it's about aliens I know so I'm So Smooth
we put on Star Wars we did accidentally John
Carpenter Star Wars
here's the thing here's the thing okay UFO
stuff what
nope not a UFOs laughing because I was like
I think that's a helicopter actually you know
standard issue helicopter
that dog gets hurt I swear to good where's
the dog coming from don't you do it don't
you do it do we never find out the dog's name
oh my God
don't love this is it is it an alien Peta
PETA
okay he's either a very bad shot or that dog
is bulletproof is he trying to tag him that's
a gun right it sounds like bullets yeah those
don't sound fun
this is a beautiful quality for like an 80s
movie which looks great he's beautiful quality
I mean he's beautiful that helps that I mean
that is the shot I saw and went beautiful
I don't understand how the agility of a dog
is taking down a helicopter and a theoretical
sharpshooter
I think the dog's the alien he's the thing
[Music]
on the dog are they gonna guess the dog what
is this classic movie don't you guess that
dog oh my God
and they missed how is he the worst shot ever
maybe they're trying to scare the dog so he
runs home so they're trying to follow him
what Corral them like a sheep I don't know
because shooting at him doesn't seem like
a good approach
up what's your plan here man you're gonna
blow up the people oh what what how do you
think oh my God what's happened
[Music]
oh God they're human beings just shot a guy
after blowing up here we're after slipping
a grenade Where Are You Gonna escape to after
shooting a guy
that's fair that's I mean I want to see the
blood of the snow Georgia yeah what's going
on there he looks like Rupert Grint but it
does like night at the cabinet like modern
Rupert Grint whoa that guy's cool looking
look at those eyebrows brows it's beautiful
work anti-eugine Levy
oh that explode it exploded yeah yeah [Music]
gasoline and grenades dude there were grenades
in there if you guessed the name of the dog
correctly I'll give you a hundred dollars
uh uh Mosby that's your one it's not great
obscure is the move don't feel proud of that
I Sparky
it's gonna be one of those movies isn't it
four stitches barely grazed it what were they
doing Flying that low shooting in a dog at
us yeah good question it's fair Cabin Fever
who knows U.S number 31 calling mcmurdle come
in over podcasters first we got smash
look to anybody on this entire continent and
you want me to reach somebody yes good recap
that's kind of the point of the radio in general
I think it's your job probably maybe we had
whirlwind oh okay Greg mentioned Tarantino
I get it now I can't condone it much myself
but it is a short haul now or there an hour
back [__] doc I'll give you the lift nope
nope I won't forget it Palmer hey thanks for
thinking about it though [Laughter] it's quite
the sausage fest it is a lot of dudes the
thing is like that's what it's about ten things
very subtle this is really 10 Things I Hate
About You
start beefing with each other I can't get
over how good his beard is yeah it's like
an immaculately thick beard it's really good
you don't want to fly we don't fly you really
want to save those crazy sweets Norwegians
Which Way doc Southwest gonna have through
the map because I'm going to be busy kind
of crazy how they shot this I mean unbelievable
looking just all the white out and lighting
it must have sucked Lighting in snow and reflection
of it all yeah this man is in Sons of Anarchy
the prequel before I also miss movies being
lit so you can actually see everything yeah
like it's a bright movie but it's still tense
okay there goes the UFO oh look at the UFO
it's crazy I can't identify it at all no one
can tell what it is what are you flying object
no will you turn that crap down I'm trying
to get some sleep I was shocked today
[Music] this must be this song is the 70s
right yeah I love when movies do that and
don't pretend like they're decades the only
decade that it drives me yeah because I don't
listen to Jess today because today's music
sucks [Music] I talk superstitious you can
tell those lyrics are poignant here though
I'm telling you that's the whole point if
you believe in things that you don't understand
you suffer
okay Shadow what you got oh I think something's
off of that dog not Swedish imagine all week
Theory we assume the dog is good because dogs
are great no we don't you clearly the dog's
not good that's what I'm saying is that we're
gonna find them all dead because the dog killed
because like we as an audience are like why
are you shooting at the dog but instead it's
it's playing an expectation yeah the thing
is inside the dog yeah and it's already gotten
these Folk [Music]
the dog through the ax 100 yeah The Shining
[Music] everything was just so bright and
now it's such a gorgeous set yeah
[Music]
froze bled some too you say blood soap true
Frozen blood icicle let's go that is metal
is fudge oh like instantaneously Frozen [Music]
the hell happened here come on Doc
he could have been Han Solo oh it'd been great
would have been great I mean I love Harrison
Harrison Ford's perfect I'm just like in this
era looking at him it's like damn it would
have been different but totally A vibe or
Indie honestly they've got kind of similar
it's that like stoic badass thing yeah like
you want to know more but he won't tell you
let me dig through your beard for all of your
secrets wherever you keep your secrets bearded
man [Music] it remains of some animal buried
in the ice and they chopped it out but where
is it look at this was that a suitcase or
kerosene it said on the thing like different
kind of gasoline like a different fuel those
companies
[Music] to bury them that's kind also frozen
ground that's gonna be a [__]
they brought them home
[Music]
even though Frozen still smells that bad well
it's steaming so I think it's like thawing
so all the smells would be coming out keep
it outside man Blair I'd like you to start
an autopsy right away this moment is your
impression that this is the thing right now
I think the thing killed that okay I think
the thing is the hunter not the body you think
this is a human body I think it was I think
it's like a mutilated remain of a couple bodies
[Music] oh two yeah see like it looks like
a like a cell dividing I'm wondering if when
this thaws out it is the thing and that the
monsters it's like we're gonna see a monster
is two-headed I don't know I I think your
theories I don't trust him mine's all based
on not trusting me okay I don't trust Mosby
he seems sketchy no drugs no alcohol
oh
man the makeup is good in this I am repulse
that's why he's in the open credits
it's so bad stop squeezing it so much my dude
is so viscous it was a Jello appears to be
anyway a normal City internal organs
art of your mouth
[Music] to be normal
so it was a dude there's an eyeball yeah this
is like splitting why you say dude I mean
it looks male that's what men look like to
you from Boston no wonder you're into women
that's true that's if that's the competition
I know it's sad I fall on I keep thinking
that they're in like a submarine that's what
it feels like it's so isolated it feels like
lost you know yeah and I think the framing's
helping that like that sense of enclosed spaces
and it's getting tighter totally there's a
hole outside but it feels like that and the
outside does like have a black and white vastness
like you talked about so I like when it's
inside its color and dense
with the others where it belongs what's his
name you just said this mutt I know but somebody's
got a name
I don't know if I trust him is he sleeping
things gonna wreck [Music] why do they have
so many dogs out there I don't think it's
companionship is there like a liquid yeah
or something are they sled dogs
Little Shop of Horrors that was graphic
oh wait what it keeps on furling yeah now
it's got like The Faculty tentacles
[Music]
it feels like something's inside yeah I think
that's the thing totally but can he transform
back and forth or oh or is it just like yeah
I don't know oh [Music] oh that guy's dead
I feel like it did this it was in the other
body as the host and now it's moving back
now it's yeah
I mean that's fair
[Music]
wow he is just so interesting like he's striking
but let's look different it's weird and pissed
off whatever it is go get child Mac wants
the flamethrower Mac wants to why that's what
he said now move smart I like that this movie
just knows skip the five steps goes right
to the flamethrower yeah
come on Charles I think it's the first name
we've heard Mack wants the flamethrower two
names
oh it's like a dog shell
so that's practical what like what's under
that oh it's like threading out to get into
the next thing oh it's spreading into the
other dogs I think
why is he stop why was he stopping him I think
he felt for the dogs but that dog was dead
foreign
I would have let it burn a lot yeah I would
not have put that out yet
up podcaster he's just got sunglasses at night
inside Antarctica [Music] it's like eating
lobster oh that's why I don't do it I don't
mess with lobster that's why I got a kick
me out of Boston no it's a Boston boy I wasn't
welcome anymore they told me to leave they're
like little cockroaches of the ocean you like
clam chowder oh Mexican food's better it's
why I'm out here do you love Mexican food
and it doesn't look like the thing when this
thing attacked our dogs it tried to digest
them absorb them the process shape its own
cells to imitate them imitate them so it's
not taking them over it's trying to be we
got to it before it had time to finish finish
what finish imitating these dogs so what does
that mean that they got to it before I had
time to finish that he's out there just not
full-blown dog I'm assuming there'll be some
sort of humanoid at some point how long were
you alone with that dog I don't know an hour
and a half maybe what the hell you looking
at me like what are you getting at it's nothing
at all I think he's wondering how long it
would take what's that looks like something
buried under the ice a helicopter UFO remember
we did start in space here
is it the place where they're spending most
of their time pretty nasty out Mac 35 knots
grew it I'm gonna go up anyway not a nautical
term yeah Memorial that hat is majestic this
has to be a UFO switch right it has to be
we met one at the top oh that's cool it's
a painting they just stood in front of I feel
like one of you should stay up there at least
okay yeah it felt like all three of them were
about to go down let's go see what happens
yeah how long you figure this has been in
the ice I'd say the Isis buried in is 100
000 years old at least so it's thawing out
the aliens a hundred thousand okay we are
going back
was that where they're buried dude maybe that's
where they they got out thousands of years
ago it crashes and this thing gets thrown
out or crawls out and it ends up freezing
in the ice I just cannot believe any of this
Voodoo [__] he's so young uh he's got
a great voice he works all the time now
[Music]
well this is I guess in this assimilation
if they are correct about it well assembly
likes to take over right so like it's saying
that it has assimilated I thought this was
the assimilation of what they think is happening
no I think no that's Refrigeration yeah
remember in the find of the century that's
going to win somebody the Nobel Prize okay
I don't trust it because when they rushed
out to meet the helicopter it felt like there
was like 20 of them but now I don't know like
you uh got the keys I didn't trust it there's
something wrong with Blair he's locked himself
in his room and he won't answer the door he
needs to be alone and in close proximity with
the life form to be absorbed so is Blair cracking
up or what in Blair that was cool get some
sleep
kind of rooting for this guy to die I mean
I don't like him [Music] you run right at
minimum
at minimum
that's all he had to say he did run I thought
he ran towards the guy and I was like bro
what are they doing out here in the first
place I think they're scientists but they
have army vehicles that's a good point
that's my way to get there [Music] whoa
[Applause] [Music]
yeah he's gonna light him on fire got to they've
shown that works yeah yep [Music] foreign
[Music]
for 10 years he's my friend you gotta burn
the rest of them is it only 10 but like I
don't know I wish we knew this movie does
not care if you like its characters know its
characters it's really about the yeah like
the horror of it that's kind of cool even
know what they're sciencing
[Music] oh so they have to burn the rest of
them because if if the organism stays any
cells yeah it seems like they can divide yeah
they gotta go find the original guy that was
with the dog who locked himself in the room
that they questioned yes oh and the chef I
can't find Blair okay if I Blair okay Blair
Windows is in the radio room still trying
to get through everyone else in the rec room
you go on I'll be in in a minute don't do
that don't trust it here we go find Blair
because Blair's obviously been infected yeah
Blair's gonna be our first human one I think
like fully formed it can be in multiple places
at multiple times that's why I think it's
a spring yeah yeah nobody gets in and out
of here nobody
podcaster got messed up go around to the bathroom
door talk to him
so he's going crazy because he's been slightly
infected by this thing I assume he's not an
imitation because I don't think I could replicate
this level but maybe
like why is he doing this because he's going
crazy I'm guessing come on man you don't want
to hurt anybody
[Music] does he know podcasters in the room
I don't think so I think he would have killed
him yeah oh cool really cool good use of tables
yeah that's why you asked for the table to
Ram them damn
great Foley work yeah I was just thinking
I want him in my shack we'll lock him in the
tool ship
are they carrying the doctor or I think I
think the Dr Blair yeah
what kind of drugs just stupefy you what happened
I think they're gonna like exorcism it out
like is he crazy or possessed might have nothing
to do with the guy remember at the beginning
they were like you can go crazy down here
which I imagine happens a lot so probably
that it was just paired wide
hey what why don't you just trust in the Lord
works out great see how that goes for you
watch Clark and watch him close did you hear
me watch him the dog guy is his name Clark
because he was around for around half Clark
so when he locked himself with her I think
so I thought he had locked himself in a room
everyone that's seen this movie is judging
us so hard I know because they're like they
should know this here's the truth it doesn't
matter this movie is awesome oh it's riveting
there's no plot like it's not a full plot
movie and you don't know the characters it's
an experience movie yeah how do we know who's
human if I was an imitation how would you
know if it was really me I'll break Agatha
Christie yeah love this possibly have been
thinking about a blood serum test you could
take a sample of each person's blood but mix
it with uncontaminated blood as if there's
a reaction we'd know who isn't human classic
we've got whole blood and storage let me start
working on it keep an eye on Clark he's close
to that dog yeah that must be Clark we've
got like half the names now you think Clark's
a red herring I think so it knows what this
organ is but get the rest of his notebooks
start going through but is he far gone because
of the space Madness or like alien man I think
it's the spaceman because like I'd go crazy
there and then the stimuli the alien Lake
gushy
oh [__] bro what where's clock right here
wait a minute wait a minute was this broken
into the lockers on I feel like the doctor's
the one then 100 who's got access to it yep
who else could I use that key I just give
it a cover whenever he needs it could anybody
have gotten it from Utah I don't see how as
soon as I'm finished I return it right away
it's got a nose ring I told you the nose ring
guy just missed it the only one who's got
any business with it oh now wait a minute
Gary you've been in here on several occasions
yeah me too I would be too yeah put it down
Gary you don't want to hurt anybody on the
floor
now I don't want him to die yeah suddenly
endearing because I'm him he took off the
glasses yeah now he's not such a d
you can shoot them is he I love this because
you don't know
all right place your bets red herring dog
guy Giles is fine one of the other three could
it be Kurt he's too big a movie star
[Music] like he's destroying all the evidence
to like seem like he got it there's so many
they're growing this thing doesn't want to
show itself he wants to hide inside an imitation
it takes us over and it has no more enemies
nobody left to kill it and then it's one this
is awesome so glad I knew nothing about this
yeah me too there's a storm hitting Us in
six hours we're gonna find out who's who let
me let me know what you're gonna break the
needle in mind he's doing a real fun job okay
they're gonna do that one other thing rips
through your clothes when it takes you over
Windows found some shredded long johns but
the name tag was missing nobody trusts anybody
now make everybody take their pants off that's
the trick issue classline hit hard you should
go back into the other room everybody get
naked right now let me see your name tags
drop trial who cut holes in their pants RJ
McCready helicopter pilot U.S Outpost North
31. helicopter pilot U.S Outpost is it like
a protection like a defense for America like
Antarctica what are we protecting from I don't
understand your job sir and everyone should
prepare their own meals and I suggest we only
eat out of cans you're really weird if you
were it and suggested that but I wouldn't
surprise me this has been very like good at
twisties any of them move you fry them you
hear anything anything at all you cut loose
on the sirens we all meet back here in 20
minutes regardless real close they roped up
dog guy definitely a red herring though I
feel like he's good [Laughter] how many of
them do you think are not okay it's like two
or three yeah at this point
wouldn't it be crazy if they're all fine they
killed them all in the First Act
they're not gonna address it
won't harm anybody you've got to let me come
back inside you saw what I saw right yeah
there was a news between the two of them and
it was hanging tangling like what foreign
he might be yeah his innocent face I don't
trust it and they first offered him to be
the guy oh the leader yeah it was stash in
his own oil furnace when must this lasted
but I don't think he saw me fighting I cut
him moose he's one of them what do you think
he got to him I don't know so that's Mac yeah
which is Russell so he must be because he
yeah like he got his clothes on yeah hello
do you think he's changed
hit a guideline cut it loose anyone messes
with me and the whole campus put those torches
on the floor and back off badass move yeah
ba move smooth bomb move
free this what happened
[Applause] oh clear oh
[Music] okay I guess correctly that he had
it inside him uh oh God [Music]
[Music]
unbelievable looking incredible work
oh
that's so cool
[Laughter] do they not see the head I don't
think this I think it's under a chair or something
those are like things coming out of his come
on yeah yeah I mean that's tradition for alien
things
Roger does Roger's on it
all right you're getting a little flamethrower
happy I do worry there's an entire building
you're in everybody's down real tight what
for for your health [Music] you would also
he just blew up the other guy why would it
be him that's close enough Clark he ain't
tying me up then I'll have to kill you child
then kill me he does look familiar to me he's
in Requiem for a Dream yeah bad guy I think
I've seen it he's a lot of stuff he's really
really talented I guess you do oh
I don't think he had the thing nope just just
dude we're gonna find out who's the thing
wash the knife bro not watching it denim's
very sanitary like if you the organism might
oh
podcaster's name is Windows you should have
switched to Mac should have would have gone
better for you Mac and windows sooth saying
this new before wow
I'm back and I'm a PC one's cool one's nerdy
it's all right there oh yeah you also didn't
see him stab him like he could have maybe
I don't know
it's a clever test though
I'll show you what I already know [Laughter]
oh yeah
now Clark
Clark oh they're on his dad right yeah I think
on the right yeah
and clock was human huh which makes you a
murderer don't it I mean he swung Adam his
instincts don't agree oh Palmer you were the
only one that could have got to that blood
cool
oh
why is Windows just hanging out oh no [Music]
Palmer was really Incognito for a minute that's
what happened yep oh
what's up with your flamethrower very unreliable
[Music]
I don't know that you can get more fire it's
pretty on fire [Music]
what a stunt it's gonna be real cold inside
now yep
now the organisms are everywhere let's breathe
it in just keep breathing [Music]
[Music] he got eight
go to the board games what are we gonna do
we know that oh okay so we still tests
no it's Niles nulls nulls
learning the names like third out what are
Childs it is child's wait now it's not Niles
and Childs are those Childs I thought it was
like Giles I don't remember what I thought
it was originally now
how would they play this on TV I remember
like this was on like TNT when we were kids
like what how what do you show we're going
out to give Blair the test if he tries to
make it back here and we're not with him I
don't know who the him left so it's child's
now now Mack and the eyebrows yeah okay I
don't know if we've gotten eyebrows his name
yet no he just did oh what was it I don't
know it was in the petri dish but his hand
was over it [Music]
oh that sounds okay and he's out he escaped
but also he's his shoulders have noose
he's in there
I nope I wouldn't not nope why is there like
how many days did you guys leave him
it's a spaceship player's been busy out here
all by himself how long was he out there what
you stole the parts from the helicopter smart
SOB put it together piece by piece where was
he trying to go space any place but here okay
that's the first part of the movie that actually
doesn't make full sense because like somebody
explained that if that was like two days and
they wouldn't have just put him so maybe he'd
been working on for a lot longer that's what
he does but then they accidentally put him
in that building above it yeah maybe foreign
[Music]
ADR moment cut to their faces we need this
plot point they did a focus group did you
guys understand that they were not going to
get out of their life throw it in we should
say it directly someone should have explained
the ship to us how did he build it we need
lots yeah that part that's the only thing
so completely flabbergasted yeah [Music]
it's a caterpillar in there so they're trying
to heat things up so that this thing can't
freeze wherever it is they don't know where
it is
practice
do you think that there is a rescue team that's
going to come and somebody's going to get
out alive I I'm thinking it's gonna be pretty
nihilistic and they all die yeah but also
the alien could just wander into the cold
and and hibernate right I was thinking that
like
why it's not stuck there maybe he's lonely
he just wants to be home with his friends
generator room
because I think we 10 or 15 minutes left in
this see I can't tell if it's like a denouement
or if the third act's gonna end like yeah
some of this is so built out like
we also never really get in a sense of setting
yeah which works for the mystery I've just
realized we haven't been anywhere like this
yet yeah
so cold to film yeah like they look freezing
gone gone crazy yeah how do you fix that we
got to bring this whole place right down into
the ice Gary Planters in the old storage room
all down by the generator no no
do you think you'd be nice to know no that
was no not now just no no no
oh
so now they all trust each other but they
can't trust a third of them now and he knows
to do that Roger whatever his name Gary you
know Roger Gary nulls no it's not now Todd
no Todd was at the beginning the name that
we read a real person
so the guy who was shooting the doctor he
was crazy the whole time he was infected the
whole time yeah and he was building a thing
so I'm wondering if like he was infected before
the movie started to me that's what makes
it why he was able to build it that whole
time because he's an alien creature you know
the dog brought it didn't it or was it already
there because if the dog brother is still
only like a week yeah but he alien moved fast
you saw flash that's true that's your quick
aliens
that thing with the face with the holes was
um the whole thing yeah and they dragged him
away by his own face like putting your fingers
in somebody's so cool okay
maybe he doesn't want to leave yet thing because
he wants them all to die first oh maybe
oh we're going full like lovecraftian
well there that goes
please [Music] time to do a somersault
gotta look cool [Music]
it looks so non-cg so real it's just so beautiful
it's so nice to see an explosion it was like
that was like we built this thing yeah yeah
yeah like they blew up a chunk of Antarctica
for us yeah yeah where do you think they shot
this maybe they're they look cold there's
space I feel like maybe Alaska Alaska ever
so off to get a little accent oh how did he
survive that I don't know but when he started
walking away I knew that the movie was going
to make him survive it because he had a great
last line that's why that's why he's got the
temperature up all over the camp it won't
last long though yeah we've got any surprises
for each other I don't think we're in much
shape to do anything about it what do we do
play here for a little while see what happens
uh it seems like a non-plan like dying
yeah cool I was kind of hoping they would
do that I like that a lot I like the the nihilistic
ending okay let's get everybody's name okay
McCready uh-huh that was Wilford Brimley as
Blair a name that we missed complete okay
nulls TK Carter Palmer I think we said one
maybe I don't know which one though Keith
David's name child's child's
sorry Norris we might have said in the beginning
I don't think don't think I said bendings
Clark Gary I know I threw a Gary in there
at least once Gary was said Fuchs the other
Tom Waits wait which one was podcast he was
winning Wednesday yeah yeah not a PC Norwegian
yeah wow there's very few actors oh yeah it's
just the people yeah like lives like a bottle
movie almost because it was like one set which
is cool which is why I think they blew it
up oh stun people y'all 10 of them thanks
guys that's great that's incredible like this
is most the credits that's in like that's
it yeah what it takes to make a movie based
on a story who goes there did you know that
no I wonder if it's like an alien paranoid
Thriller and they just moved it up I like
who goes there as a title but the thing is
just got so much power to it pop it's lasted
what 40 years like the thing is still one
of those classic titles and the font and everything
I had this moment a few times in the movie
where I kept thinking like this feels like
a classic movie like when you're watching
it and you're like oh this is important it
was so simple yeah um and just like unbelievably
executed like you know when you re-watch movies
from your childhood like predator or alien
or any of the movies that we actually did
see yeah and they feel like nostalgic yeah
this felt nostalgic the first time like there
was elements I know what you mean where you're
just like oh like that makes sense that this
says with the test of time yeah it's just
it whole it holds up I guess there's like
a built-in importance because it's like so
meticulous but also freeing it was not until
we got to the like whodunit aspect of it not
even who or who is it yeah that I was like
I see what why this is the thing yeah the
First Act I was like oh it's a cool Creature
Feature totally and and the because of the
costume because of the design because of all
that I was like oh okay this is a this is
a classic yeah but then when we got to the
actual premise when we got to like what where
what we're supposed to be guessing feeling
yeah then I was like oh that's why this this
that's why this is still watched still talked
about and I'd seen some of the design like
some of those gifts are iconic like the things
exploding and the guy's head coming off the
shoulder like that but I still never knew
anything which is cool like we got to watch
this fresh 40 years later it it didn't feel
like it is a horror movie but it didn't feel
so scary it because it felt real it felt like
oh this is how I would be feeling if I was
there no one did stupid stuff yeah like no
one ran upstairs so there's a couple of times
where we were like don't do that don't go
down there yeah but overall still I'm a little
unclear on how he built that spaceship no
idea I have I'm gonna ask everyone immediately
after this it's fine though that's fine it
was still I mean it allowed a ticking Time
Bomb like you need that incident in the third
act yeah but it definitely felt like we needed
it not that it made sense yeah definitely
how do you feel about the fact that we don't
know any of the characters I think I would
be bothered by it if it wasn't for the level
of suspense we still felt yeah like you and
I were still riveted without the names totally
and usually you're not watching something
having to repeat the name you just don't know
and then you see and you're like oh that's
who where he was you know I prefer this to
those scenes where it's like hello Tom how
are you today yeah and you're like wow yeah
there was very little Exposition in this honestly
and there is very little like I knew no one
yeah they didn't care if you did and I think
that is a unique sense of tension because
you have to like them or not immediately and
like then like Windows grow on us and stuff
yeah podcast boy podcast yeah Windows was
uh interesting and then the other part that
the other guy that was interesting was the
guy that dies right before Windows where we
shot him right and and they'll find out he's
human and we both thought it was a red herring
but I like that they kept manipulating that
by having him tied up and we were like okay
are they doubling down yeah yeah completely
and I really liked Childs the whole time but
I liked that we were supposed to to be suspicious
but I couldn't tell if that's because I know
the actors work I don't think it's a surprise
that Childs and Mac are the two at the end
too because child's the only one who even
though he didn't know his name he's the only
one who we knew right and he seemed capable
the whole time yeah which I like that everyone
that like survived were the ones that you
could hope in the beginning would is your
interpretation at the end that the one of
the two of them has the thing in them my interpretation
is that they die and the thing still survives
because like it could just go out in the cold
but like if he so it in either of them then
the things still ready well the thing was
you know the dog and all the things were represented
so it could be that was the everything like
all of it that was left but I don't feel like
that would be enough with the things we got
shown I think that the thing the thing needs
a host to live sure and without hosts then
so there's only two hosts left right I'm assuming
that that the doc we said the big thing that
happened at the end was the doc mixed with
the guy everything left yeah so that's dead
because we um through a dynamite at it right
so I'm assuming that either the thing is dead
or it's in child's or Mac so using one of
them well I think that the problem is Max
says why don't we just sit here and wait it
out which is what somebody who has the host
in them would say because you want to and
Charles is so tired he didn't do anything
to test anything right but if you so if you
don't have it in you not to be but you should
off yourself right you know if as an audience
member we're watching going I trust Kurt Russell
because we just saw him take out the other
thing right but from a dialogue and an ending
standpoint you know you're gonna die either
way right so if I didn't have it in me in
that moment I would burn the other person
right and then eliminate all options and yeah
like get rid of variables but they don't and
they're both there right and we know they
can't both be the thing or they would know
that they were both the thing and then they
would just be fine I do kind of feel like
one of them is the thing do you think it like
left like a piece of it was able to get into
him no maybe I think child if anyone because
he just stumbles up like hey I was just looking
for Blair yeah and that seemed like a line
yeah I'm with you I'm with you but if it isn't
child then Kurt in 15 minutes you're gonna
have to snap into it Mac and you're gonna
have to see I think Mac was just out like
he was just done like I don't think he had
anything left to fight like I don't think
he had any he said that but no I think he's
gonna wake up he's like you think the thing
too is like this very clearly set up so that
there could be a sure and that was a big thing
in the 80s yeah I mean there's serialized
content now but there's not a lot of sequels
now you know what I mean like this felt like
it could have a sequel not like a franchise
this is a uh I guess I don't know this for
a fact I assume there is no thing too I don't
think I've heard of a thing too or if it wasn't
well loved because this is beloved and I've
heard the thing too yeah do you feel like
they could do that today well so at one of
the major strengths of this is the Prosthetics
and the Practical yeah but that was one of
the only flaws I had was at the end when you
see the full size of it there was a moment
I would have liked another 10 seconds before
he blew it up so I felt the sense of dread
intention because I felt like you're like
it was like big reveal and all of a sudden
it was like awesome line of dialogue like
80s and then it then it was over so there
was all this escalation and then the actual
climax moment was so short so I think that
was because they could only show it so much
because you'll notice once it was fully formed
they like hit a lot of it for budgetary purpose
yeah and just for like design because you'd
want it like the fear of the thing is how
amorphous and alien it is so if you show too
much it's less scary so I do feel like the
only weakness in that last beat was that it
was like all this building building and it
explodes whereas I would have I think modern
audiences there'd be a bit more of that like
build to the oh no he's not gonna make it
but I don't want to see this with CGI like
this was this would not work with a CGI villain
and do you think that today doing this with
practicals would just make it too expensive
to even make money I don't think studios are
willing to risk what this would take today
because otherwise a lot a lot of movies be
better because half the time you see bad C
drives like well they should have taken a
chance and done practical and they just don't
like I really worry about the fact that we're
cutting corners on the movies that make a
billion dollars so why would a movie that
maybe make my like 500 million dollars yeah
because if the big studios are cutting corners
on CGI there's no way they're going to invest
in the human element if they did do a thing
today I feel like they would have to almost
like I I don't feel like Kurt Russell is in
it and is like hears that there's something
goes like I feel like we still don't know
what happened and then you just put the other
pieces one of them got out and I think the
only way to do it today is to do the second
act and later creature and do it a tiny budget
film and make the first act all suspense and
who done it you know what I can't stand about
myself that like the first thing I'm thinking
about when this ends because of the ambiguity
of it is like a sequel yeah and it's like
wait that movie was bomb it was full circle
like it was enough but then my 2023 brain
is like but what see my thought is that the
ending being ambiguous is good because it
doesn't have a sequel so I have the same thought
like what if there's a sequel glad there's
not I think yeah no I'm glad there's not two
but I will but I wish there were I'm glad
there's not but see I I'm getting a little
franchised out yeah completely you're that's
absolutely right like when cocaine buried
and I was like that was a cocaine bear and
like I felt good about like all right that's
a whole last movie whereas like I'm very worried
about the fact that I I like your thought
I was like what sounds different do you not
like cocaine bear isn't that supposed to be
made for me and I was just like it's a movie
about a bear on cocaine no it wasn't bad and
I loved that about it it wasn't the thing
though I mean it's not gonna be like we're
not gonna talk about cool camera for 40 years
so what do you think in terms of did this
hold like people talking about this oh this
was definitely the movie that I was promised
okay you yeah I almost feel like I thought
I wasn't gonna like it as much uh another
I haven't seen what is it the fly is that
the other thing we'll talk about Jeff Goldblum
yeah he's the fly um I think and I I don't
know in my head I think I like confused the
tooth the thing of the fly I'm one of these
article noun movies I don't know Cronenberg
but there's article nouns I haven't seen a
lot of these types of movies so I kind of
they all blur together a little bit not not
that the Flies this type of movie just like
I love this it's like a creature review something
like that yeah I haven't seen a lot of movies
from the 80s and I haven't seen a lot of horror
movies from the 80s so all I knew didn't know
that this had anything to do with aliens I
didn't know that it was gonna be Kurt Russell
I didn't know that it was going to be Antarctica
like a desolate like I did didn't know anything
about this so I just had heard that a lot
of my horror friends loved it so I thought
it would be really scary yeah and very nostalgic
so I was really pleasantly surprised that
I think that this is just like a true great
movie beginning middle end that didn't do
the things that usually I care about which
is like backstory and character it just or
plot development like it didn't do any of
that and I still loved it which is interesting
it to me was the thing that I think a lot
of Studios try to espouse which is like turn
your brain off and enjoy it and it wasn't
turned to burn off because it's dumb it was
we don't need all that stuff you just described
but successfully like some people say theme
park ride about like Transformers and stuff
and that doesn't feel good whereas this is
a theme park ride that felt good like it was
fulfilling as a ride the experience was fulfilling
yeah I really I really F with that movie yeah
I thought this was spectacular that was really
good I also think that it was nostalgic in
that I recognized some of the influences but
it didn't feel like I was worried about where
like when I watched The Godfather I'd already
seen Men in Tights 100 times so I felt like
I'd already seen like the comedy version so
by the time I watched The Godfather I was
like I liked it but I didn't feel that like
profound sense of like Cinema I was like oh
that was a movie whereas this I could see
how it influenced things but I didn't feel
like I'd already seen it yeah wow this is
really good yeah dug this and also I could
see why Cronenberg influenced a lot of filmmakers
I can see like the cronenbergian uh use of
special effects which is referenced I know
uh Fantastic Four a lot of people tried to
make a Cronenberg body horror thing multiple
times didn't work but like I definitely feel
the impact of this movie without and also
the gifts and things I've seen like memes
of it but it didn't ruin the experience I
knew Kurt Russell was in it only because of
memes but it didn't make me it didn't change
anything yeah and also just not with horror
but with mystery also yeah it's definitely
yeah I think we're in the middle of it you're
like Knives Out moment yeah Agatha Christie
yeah all of a sudden I was like they're they're
going to have that thing where they're trying
to figure out who's the the bad one on the
playing trainer automobile yeah and you can
see at the second that we start questioning
in the car like wait he's been there what's
happening here and you start thinking oh my
God some of them have it and I love that this
is probably going to be fun for people to
watch because we hadn't seen it and they have
like a lot of people probably grew up watching
this and they would be like what what a silly
thing for adults to not know and so that's
gonna be joyous to see them think we know
what's going on we never did did you in the
last two hours come up with the name of somebody
from Boston that is uh a woman um I can't
say it did you uh that's how I was in the
movie I was I was so enthralled in the film
it at one point halfway through I was like
oh Sarah Silverman and then I was like oh
no no it's because she's a Jew not because
she's from Boston you're like okay let me
process women in filmmaking wait wrong category
what have I done uh yeah so we don't know
if that's gonna stay in the cut but uh at
one point uh Roxy and I were just trying to
name people from Boston only dudes came to
mind but there are women in Boston there are
and they the many talented successful ones
that's one of them I uh well you're out here
you know what you're the first woman from
Boston yeah you did it JoJo went to Northeastern
I don't know he's from Boston though that's
the thing it's so tricky we're gonna we're
gonna solve this mystery that's the thing
uh people in the comments leave your favorite
woman from Boston let us know who you enjoy
from that world has nothing to do with the
thing but we're curious uh this was awesome
I had so much fun this actually lived up to
very lofty expectations if there are any other
Cronenberg films 80s films Thrillers anything
you think we might not have seen because that's
a definitely a void in my film knowledge blind
spot for me like I don't have it maybe the
fly I'd love to watch the fly if you enjoyed
this uh like share subscribe that way we know
that you did that'll inform us to maybe watch
The Fly let us know in the comments what you
want us to check out next thank you for being
a reject we appreciate you all very much we
will see you next time for more or koi and
Roxy don't watch movies from before they were
born but should here in real Rejects foreign